[Music]
and we are live I'll or podcast lord
gaben dinette lor Cognito here with the
legendary eric chahi of another world
fragrance is a legend in the game and
right now we are debuting paper beast we
are and we have Lord gene giving it the
psvr full treatment as he's going
through it this is absolutely awesome
what we're seeing right here right now
again it's a nice to do this looks
really cool very the environmental looks
really cool I don't know what that is I
wish I was experiencing it like gene is
experienced again but whatever it is it
looks cool and one thing about Eric
chahi makes some very cool world designs
so this is going to be very cool to ask
gene when he's done with this experience
how his experience has gone and if I
could ask the legend a question while
we're talking so what's going on at this
point Eric what's happening right now
well it's the beginning of the adventure
and so in this game you discover an
artificial world but it's a wide world
Philip wildlife okay let's cover animals
Wow but very curious animals and exotic
animals but have their own behavior and
prepare is the first Explorer on this
world okay which is grown out of the
data of the internet so it is an
artificial world in a simulation but no
one seen before so it's as you can see
by the sky and there is the cloud
it's literally the cloud will be later
yeah I see the clouds yeah so get a
simulated world artificial world you're
the first person to discover yes and
you're now in this world and what is it
seeing different types of wildlife
different types of creatures exactly
okay and each creature has its own
personality
you see this one is little indirect his
little ggressive he wants to catch
recorder that's awesome there is and the
key thing is that this game is built on
the top of simulation so conceived a
creature working for example they work
by algorithm oh so it means that every
footstep every motion is adapt in
real-time what is happening I'm
butchering and any action for the player
or over animals can see if you're your
friend just grab this creature yeah and
it had up immediately to it with motion
wow this is so it's a lot of algorithm
going on here with this game I will yes
we were for four years on this game for
years and the first years was to design
commission system nice nice so four
years of development this game and and
right now as far as DD I know you said
he goes to discover worlds are there
other worlds we can discover also in
this game well this is the initial world
right now that the players will be
immersed in what you what you're seeing
now it's the first area in this world
and each area has different ambience
different mood or pacing is very strange
even but happening in this in this world
and
we will see one soon okay let's go
I like that the world has different
varied areas and it just feels like a
sense of discovery finding things out in
these different areas these different
very parts of this world that's it and
yes and very so there is a story okay my
next question my next question but like
another world touch of a hoedown like
another world and I never okay there is
no world the old story is here by the
behavior of the animals and what is
happening in this world okay so there is
no text no something really pure awesome
that's touch really directly the heart
that is one of our field my opinion your
staples because one of the things that I
feel that makes games like this great is
that you don't give a lot of clue like
you the player learns about the game
through the environment and I love that
level of immersive storytelling and the
fact that you said that another world
has that aspect as also with paper
beasts Rose my heart and I'm new to VR
but that would get me to play a view
that this that sense of discovery
because that's what games like another
world
that was why I gravitate towards it so
that the creature is now that catch by
this kind of context so
you have to really sit but how's that
control gee
this creature of this giant creature is
ready
attached to the player what is going to
think hole Wow we got a sick hole
developing right now and paper Beast Wow
see the smoke effect is stuff coming up
whoa whoa
okay
the particle effects are outstanding by
the way yeah it's it's made of physics
all system is better based on physics so
we use with physics for everything for
gameplay but also to create the universe
so this particular are the same kind of
physics but is on creature so we have a
chaotic layer juice but emotionally is
very intense as we can vary it like I
said that looks absolutely amazing my
question is as far as the engine itself
that you're using for the game is this a
created engine that you guys use or is
it based on something else like a unity
or an unreal we used unity but we
develop or in engine inside yes I guess
because I get the departed it looks
absolutely amazing each individual
particle almost like a windstorm a
sandstorm yeah and it varies bo do do we
during three years three people works on
VOD and the audio is just super precise
and can do everything around very
immersive so what would you say being at
work working on a VR title are these are
the things that kind of allow you to to
enhance immersion is that what it draws
you to VR yes it's a new lever of
immersion because you already feel the
size of object and it's more intuitive
when you interact with physically with
something you can really feel it for
example here when you drop something you
can feel the weight because there is a
kind of resistance yes yes okay I got
you again these are things that only VR
can afford rent as opposed to a
traditional experience yeah
okay this culture is funny you can see
the physical with Laurent and over and
this cultural dig the sound
this is Lord Haris right this is what
we're calling the sound box right yes I
should play with Sun box also but it's
good that you have him direct director
in the sandbox it's a free place to
experiment with all everything we
discover in the advanced yoga like
create your object you can some of them
we can get it into a sandbox
and some are only unique for the sandbox
for example here you can edit with
cheering Wow so visit varies but you
rain is simulated night
the water flows the Sun flows so within
your tan shade butchering his own way
and then he can populate it with future
will plant but world's really that level
of creation in the sandbox yeah I think
you can build your own little ecosystem
okay so this is like a creek a full
create almost a full broke radio down to
the terrain yes
chiren plants and culture in case we
were to Wow you won't rain you just drop
so we could do a wind right rain for us
whatever elements can we do great first
okay we have a lot of creation that we
did in this game
and you have a nice subject we have our
cloud
this is crazy because like I had no idea
what Lord chahiye is telling us is that
beyond just a narrative based game we
also have this sandbox feature which I
had no idea about services for tornadoes
with
there is so much going on okay so you
can have a step back and you have very
rarely a good view at be environment
okay
he launched maybe a storm now that's why
we will change totally
[Music]
about all the variation in accessibility
with terrain wide there is a storm and
the water is pudding everywhere so it
will erode with terrain and criteria
River Wow okay we have a full sandbox
here fully operational setback that we
are creating this is pretty immersive
he's just place the ball now did you
encounter like I mean it there's a lot
of things you're able to put on screen
like this is very impressive the the
sheer amount of things that are
happening at the same time with the
algorithm you mean the number of
entities
yes
yeah you can have a good bunch of
entities
it depends some entities are broken or
CPUs unless you see there is a gorge yes
so when it's full you reach my maximum
carry that was my next question
yeah so pretty much your your that
greengage that is where you can after
once you fill that up then that's your
limit as far as more things you can you
can implant in implement into the
sandbox excuse me okay that's the green
bar right yeah once that reaches the max
oh yes yeah there is another tool to
remove tools so you can remove an entity
event but because we don't again got it
we gotta understand now I got it why
this is very very cool very cool this
level of creativity is very very cool
Lord gene has that sandbox feeling it is
old
he's a desert right there this is
amazing he's creating that is amazing
that shot right there you see the old
map is Fiza is praise it's over what
you're first and we anymore with
postcards left
it's awesome so my question to you
Lauren
what inspired this game natural natural
beauty of natural and just not something
performers just
a little square are we which is working
I'm really fascinated by
the diversity of life how they world the
diversity of motion
that's why we focus first on the
locomotion of the Lafayette and beside
this oh that's interesting
we change it once from the Sun into
water you can transform one matter into
another another material yeah so what
what really is touching today's so very
swiss-based bite life in a real world
which which is badly treated by but here
this white light is inside the big data
and is a it's pretty hidden
so it's preserved its order it's very
kind of interesting meaning we there's a
message there I see the message but if
it buries a connection to the data to
you so just a curious combination of you
mentoring a wide life but is connected
to the data so you have quite sure that
it piece of paper tomato origami and so
also bad this is awesome so in
conclusion can wrap up soon but the game
looks for now the concept is unique yes
it's very cool I love the aspect of
nature I love the aspect of creativity
weather effects changing the terrain and
then in conjunction with all of this you
have a story mode where pretty much
you're learning at different parts of
the planet in the different moods of the
planet how far are we from paper-based
possibly releasing or psvr which would
be trees
and to moon 400 whistles super proof
we're super close all right you heard it
here first paper beast psvr with
absolute gaming legend himself Erik chai
Lord Eric chahi the man who created
another one one of my childhood favorite
games this is an absolute pleasure to
have you in the realm of the aisle all
podcast very much a dream of mine to be
the childhood hero you heard it here
first
I love podcast cause it gave me that
neck
[Music]